The lead-up to Star Wars Episode IX is proving
to be pretty exciting, and leading to plenty
of wild speculation.
Strap on your helmets, nerf herders, you're
in for a bumpy ride as we explore some of
the latest spoilers and rumors from a galaxy
far, far away.
Disney decided to clean house in a big way
ahead of The Force Awakens, declaring that
all Extended Universe materials were no longer
considered Star Wars canon.
The Mouse House then set about creating its
own line of short stories, comics, and books
to tie in with the new continuity, and one
such release might just include a huge clue
about a major Episode IX character.
In Poe Dameron #27, a conversation Poe has
with Rey and Finn seems to confirm that he's
been unwittingly channeling the Force all
this time.
Marvel's Poe Dameron comics overlap with J.J.
Abrams' The Force Awakens.
#26 explained how Dameron survived that crash
and filled us in on what he did between then
and rescuing Rey and Finn from the First Order,
but it was the following issue that really
got readers talking.
In it, Dameron admits that he's been able
to tap into some kind of "energy" while flying,
prompting both Rey and Leia to suggest he's
been using the Force.
The seeds of this reveal were actually planted
in the 2015 series Star Wars: Shattered Empire,
according to CBR.
It's in this prelude to The Force Awakens
that we learn how Luke Skywalker gave remnants
of The Great Tree, a natural conduit of the
Force, to Dameron's parents, who used them
to grow a new tree at home on Yavin 4.
Dameron even mentions growing up around this
tree, further foreshadowing a connection to
the Force.
You'll need to take this Rise of Skywalker
rumor with a generous sprinkling of Crait's
finest surface salt, because it originated
from an unverified source.
According to The Sun, Ewan McGregor will return
as Obi-Wan Kenobi for the upcoming trilogy
closer, though Disney is reportedly keen to
keep that fact under wraps.
McGregor portrayed Obi-Wan in Episodes I through
III and has already reprised the role in voiceover
form, speaking directly to Rey during a Force
vision in 2015's The Force Awakens.
He recorded some brand new dialogue for his
brief audio cameo…
"Rey…These are your first steps."
…which was mixed with lines from preexisting
Star Wars movies.
His voice was actually blended with that of
original Obi-Wan actor Alec Guinness, and
more recent reports suggest that this approach
will be taken one step further in The Rise
of Skywalker.
According to Star Wars enthusiast Mike Zeroh,
J.J. Abrams will return to the moment Obi-Wan
contacted Rey in The Force Awakens and flesh
it out somewhat.
The late Jedi Master will reportedly appear
as a Force Ghost, his features altered to
somewhat resemble both McGregor and Guinness,
and offer Rey some much-needed guidance.
Dominic Monaghan of Lost and Alias' Greg Grunberg
are both in The Rise of Skywalker, but they
aren't the only Abrams alumni appearing.
Felicity star Keri Russell is also in Episode
IX, though she wasn't chosen simply because
she's part of the club.
According to Variety's Justin Kroll, Russell's
experience made her the ideal choice.
Kroll revealed:
"The role calls for action-heavy fight scenes.
Russell has shown her ability to perform tough
stunts in projects like FX's The Americans,
Mission: Impossible, and Dawn of the Planet
of the Apes."
The name of Russell's character wasn't known
at the time, but subsequent leaks shed some
light.
In March 2019, several merchandising images
appeared online, including one of a masked
woman named Zorri who appeared to be a new
bounty hunter.
"Bounty hunters?
We don't need their scum."
Fan site Making Star Wars shared the leaked
pictures, explaining:
"The images give us a good look at Zorri.
Based on what my sources have described to
me about Keri Russell's character, I can't
see how it isn't the same character."
Those sources, it appears, were dead on.
It didn't explicitly refer to her as a bounty
hunter, but Vanity Fair released a hi-res
photo of Russell as, quote, "the masked scoundrel
Zorri Bliss" after being granted exclusive
behind-the-scenes access to Episode IX, seemingly
confirming the rumors.
Bliss was shown on, quote, "the Thieves' Quarter
of the snow-dusted world Kijimi," one of two
new planets and a possible entry point for
Lando Calrissian.
How big a part will Lando play?
For fans of the original trilogy, one of the
biggest moments in the first Episode IX teaser
trailer was seeing Lando Calrissian back in
the cockpit of the Millennium Falcon.
The Hollywood Reporter revealed that Billy
Dee Williams was reprising the role in July
2018, but details of Calrissian's part in
The Rise of Skywalker were kept under wraps
in the months that followed.
Early rumors suggested that the charming smuggler
would be playing a significant role in the
saga closer, but that doesn't appear to be
the case.
While his daughter is rumored to be making
an appearance, Calrissian himself isn't likely
to feature very prominently, because J.J.
Abrams has so much to squeeze in.
Inverse predicts, quote, "Lando's screentime
in the movie will be on par with Admiral Ackbar's
short scenes in The Force Awakens."
Williams kept the details of Calrissian's
arc to himself at Star Wars Celebration 2019,
but he was happy to defend his character's
past actions.
Of his divisive betrayal of Han Solo in The
Empire Strikes Back, Williams said:
"He was up against Darth Vader, he had to
figure out something.
Besides, did anybody die?"
He makes a fair point, but this moment has
always been a bone of contention among fans.
Could Calrissian, who will apparently wear
the same getup he wore when he first met Solo,
be out to avenge his death as a way of finally
making amends?
Episode IX will tie up a number of loose ends,
after all.
One of the wildest Episode IX rumors, the
theory that Han Solo is alive, is partly backed
up by the novelization of The Force Awakens.
The book was picked apart by Uproxx, and there's
a big reveal about the Starkiller Base that
has Harrison Ford fans speculating on an unlikely
return.
The book explained what the movie didn't;
how the giant weapon is powered.
The assumption was that it harnessed the power
of the sun, but the truth is far more complicated.
Uproxx's Donna Dickens reports:
"Turns out, it was never supposed to be powered
by the sun.
Situated in one place, messing with science
they didn't understand, the First Order was
harvesting dark matter to power their weapon.
As the matter congealed to be sucked into
the core, the light was supposed to dim.
Then, using more science they barely understood,
they beamed the concentrated dark matter through
the galaxy instead of across it.
Basically, they were ripping holes in time/space."
Solo appeared to have been killed by his own
son when we saw him last, but there's now
a theoretical chance that he was sucked into
an alternate timeline before he bled out.
One fan who's excited at the prospect is director
and Star Wars fanatic Kevin Smith, who tweeted:
"[If a plot development] allows Lando to repeat
his Empire Strikes Back line 'There's still
a chance to save Han!' and get us back to
that fateful bridge on Starkiller Base?
Then I'll kiss J.J. on the mouth."
Numerous disgruntled Star Wars fans made their
disapproval of Rian Johnson's The Last Jedi
known, but the one thing that everyone seemed
to agree was done right was the surprise appearance
from Yoda.
The little green Jedi Master showed up as
a Force Ghost to help troubled former student
Luke Skywalker come to his senses and embrace
his failures, a standout moment in the highly
divisive eighth episode.
Yoda was rendered in CGI for the prequel trilogy,
but Johnson chose to go back to basics and
brought in Frank Oz to operate a slightly
updated Yoda puppet.
Creature designer Neal Scanlan said:
"We just felt that it was absolutely right
and proper that we create the puppet in the
closest likeness to the original and to give
Frank exactly what he had the first time around."
Renowned puppeteer Oz, who provides Yoda's
distinctive voice as well as his movements,
could soon be adding Episode IX to his impressive
résumé if a new report is to be believed.
According to the New York Daily News, a source
with apparent knowledge of the production
has revealed that J.J. Abrams is going to
bring Force Ghost Yoda back.
The insider dished:
"The success of the scenes featuring Yoda
in The Last Jedi were huge.
Yoda will again appear as a ghost as he acknowledges
Rey's success and growth as a Jedi."
Lucasfilm's original position on Carrie Fisher's
inclusion in future Star Wars movies was pretty
clear; she wouldn't be appearing in any.
Prior to the release of The Last Jedi, President
Kathleen Kennedy told ABC:
"Sadly, Carrie will not be in [Episode] IX."
The idea that they could digitally render
a version of Fisher like they did with Peter
Cushing's Tarkin in Rogue One was quickly
ruled out after execs met with Fisher's daughter,
Billie Lourd.
All parties reportedly agreed that it would
be disrespectful.
At the time, bringing Leia back with unused
footage from The Last Jedi was also said to
have been off the table, but things have shifted
since then.
We now have confirmation from the late actress'
brother that Fisher will indeed be in Episode
IX, with J.J. Abrams apparently set to use
footage shot for both The Last Jedi and The
Force Awakens.
According to ABC's Clayton Sandell, who spoke
to Todd Fisher on podcast The Resistance Broadcast,
the family is very happy about what Abrams
has planned.
Sandell claimed that Todd Fisher was, quote,
"very excited, the whole family is really
excited about this and wanted it to happen."
Sandell went on to explain:
"There are big surprises coming with this
movie and with this performance and with this
unused footage.
This one's really for the fans…
Sandell confirmed that there's "a number of
minutes" worth of footage from The Force Awakens
and The Last Jedi for Abrams to work with.
When ThatHashtagShow reported that Disney
wanted a female lead between the ages of 40
and 50 to play a character named Mara, many
jumped to the conclusion that this was Rey's
mother.
The character does seem to fit the bill, but
now there's a fresh rumor about Rey's mom,
and it's a shocker.
And before you say it, no, we seriously doubt
that Kylo's take on Rey's parents, that they
were nobodies who sold her for drinking money,
holds any water.
According to the theory posed by Film Threat,
Episode IX will see Rey's real mom and dad
revealed to be none other than Han Solo and
Emilia Clarke's Qi'ra.
We were introduced to Han's first love in
Solo: A Star Wars Story, a movie that could
apparently end up being all about Rey's parents.
Film Threat's prediction goes on to explain:
"Solo ended letting us know that Qi'ra has
ties to the Dark Side.
Kylo Ren is the son of Leia, a mother of the
Light Side.
Qi'ra, a mother of the Dark Side, bore a Light
Side daughter, Rey.
It's the Force balancing itself."
Of course, if this theory turns out to be
accurate, that means Han cheated on Leia and
fathered a daughter with another woman.
While this could actually explain a number
of things, such as why Kylo Ren resented his
dad so much and why he and Rey are connected
through the Force, not everyone is buying
it.
As ScreenRant points out, quote, "There's
been nothing to indicate Han was unfaithful
to Leia."
The idea of Darth Vader returning to the big
screen in Episode IX might seem ludicrous
on the surface, but Disney has been subtly
paving the way for the heavy-breathing Sith
Lord to play some part in the upcoming installment.
After reading Marvel's Darth Vader comics,
ScreenRant noticed one small detail that could
have actually been a huge moment of foreshadowing.
The ins and outs of becoming a Force Ghost
have been up for discussion among Star Wars
fans ever since Luke Skywalker passed on in
controversial fashion near the end of The
Last Jedi.
The assumption was that returning as a Force
Ghost was something only those in tune with
the light side of the Force could do, but
shouldn't the Sith have their own version
of this phenomenon?
Turns out they do, and it was explained in
the pages of the Vader comic.
In the story in question, Vader is gifted
a mask that once belonged to another powerful
Sith called Darth Momin.
Momin's "residue" was still attached to the
artifact when Palpatine gave it to his third
and final apprentice, who used it, long story,
to help erect his castle on Mustafar.
The forgotten Sith was able to influence others,
and tell his story to Vader, via the mask.
ScreenRant's prediction is that Vader will
similarly influence proceedings in Episode
IX, seeing as his grandson Kylo Ren is now
in possession of Vader's half-melted mask.
With appearances on Doctor Who and Game of
Thrones under his belt, veteran character
actor Richard E. Grant already had some major
fan cred when he was cast in The Rise of Skywalker.
As it turns out, he's a big Star Wars fanboy
himself.
The actor opened up about the moment J.J.
Abrams told him he'd be part of the final
chapter in the Skywalker saga while a guest
on the Happy Sad Confused podcast, revealing
how he was so excited that he couldn't actually
take anything in.
Grant admitted:
"I'm sure [Abrams] was telling me in detail
what part I was playing and what the character
is called, I have no memory of that whatsoever.
They kept saying, 'So you are gonna do this,
aren't you?' and I said, 'Of course I'm gonna
do this!'"
The most popular theory was that Grant would
be taking on the role of Grand Admiral Thrawn,
a popular villain reintroduced into the canon
in the third season of Star Wars Rebels, but
the actor outright debunked that rumor when
Radio Times asked him about it.
Grant dished, quote, "I'm not playing the
Star Wars character you just mentioned."
And he wasn't lying!
When Vanity Fair released a huge Episode IX
cover story in May 2019, the identity of Grant's
character was finally revealed, he's playing
a new villain named Allegiant General Pryde.
Despite being thrown to what we thought was
certain death by a remorseful Anakin Skywalker
in 1983's Return of the Jedi, Emperor Palpatine
lives.
At least, that's what Abrams seemed to suggest
with the first Episode IX teaser.
The footage ends with a shot of some Death
Star wreckage and Palpatine's unmistakable
cackle, implying that our heroes will face
off against the powerful Sith in The Rise
of Skywalker.
As if to confirm this was the case, Palpatine
actor Ian McDiarmid appeared onstage at Star
Wars Celebration 2019 during the teaser reveal.
"This was such an unexpected moment."
"I know!
It shocked me."
But how will Abrams explain his way out of
this one?
Theory crafters already have a few different
ideas.
MovieWeb reminded readers that, in the prequel
films, Palpatine has referenced Darth Plagueis,
a Sith lord so powerful and wise…
"…he could use the Force to influence the
midichlorians to create life."
Alternatively, the site argued, the Emperor
might use a loophole introduced in Star Wars
Rebels: The so-called "World Between Worlds
in the hidden Jedi Temple on Lothal."
Apparently, Palpatine, quote, "sought to manipulate
[it] as he could travel through time by using
the Force."
Elsewhere, IGN believes that Abrams might
actually be taking some inspiration from an
Expanded Universe comic.
In Dark Empire, Palpatine resurrects himself
several times via clones, transferring his
spirit to different bodies.
The first teaser for The Rise of Skywalker
gave theorists plenty to work with.
Now that the Emperor's presence has been all
but confirmed, it's safe to assume that he'll
be involved in the film's final battle.
Who, where, and how he'll be battling we don't
know for sure, but according to Making Star
Wars editor Jason Ward, there's a huge rumor
doing the rounds that pits Kylo Ren against
Palpatine, in the form of actor Matt Smith.
Yup.
This guy.
This silly dude.
Right here.
The British actor has been telling journalists
that he isn't in Episode IX, but that's contrary
to reports.
Even international Disney websites are listing
the former Doctor Who star among the cast,
and Jason Ward believes that he'll play a
critical role.
The mega fan reported:
"A really solid source over the years passed
on something they heard internally.
The rumor is that Matt Smith isn't Palpatine
reborn or rejuvenated, but a dark side acolyte…During
the final act of the film Rey and Kylo team
up to fight the Palpatine possessed Matt Smith."
Ward's inside source claims that Kylo Ren
gets possessed by the Emperor after killing
his host body, leading to a moment of redemption.
The tormented son of Han Solo and Leia Organa
has enough light left in him to lay down his
arms so Rey can finish the job, becoming Ben
Solo again in his final moments.
With Kylo Ren dead, and Rey too pure for the
Emperor to possess, the fight is won.
Most fans seemed pretty unhappy that The Last
Jedi neglected the Knights of Ren.
Kylo Ren's band of warriors appear briefly
in The Force Awakens when Rey touches Luke
Skywalker's lightsaber and triggers a vision,
but they were left out of Rian Johnson's follow-up
because he, quote, "just didn't see a place
for them in the movie."
According to Vanity Fair, we're finally going
to get some answers in the upcoming trilogy-capper,
with sources at Disney confirming theories
that the, quote, "long-rumored Knights of
Ren will finally arrive in Skywalker."
We got our first good look at the unit in
Annie Leibovitz's extensive photoshoot, and
what's immediately clear is that they're not
your typical Star Wars villains.
In contrast to the sleek and shiny look adopted
by the First Order and the Galactic Empire
before it, the Knights of Ren wear dirty,
rag-tag armor and carry over-the-top weapons.
Vanity Fair's Joanna Robinson observed:
"Their D.I.Y. look, including one especially
lethal-looking gun arm, would be equally at
home in one of the Mad Max movies."
Their identities have not yet been revealed,
though fans think they have a pretty good
idea about where they came from.
In The Last Jedi, Luke reveals that Ren vanished
with a handful of his Padawan learners when
he set the temple ablaze and turned his back
on the Jedi.
Did Luke's former students become the Knights
of Ren?
Only time, as they say, will tell.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.